[Musik]
alexis sanchez war begeistert ein ist es
freilich also wir an dem moment hallo
ihr lieben wir machen heute eine
maracuja split torte besser gesagt
schnitten und apropos ich muss jetzt
kurz wegging ich würde am liebsten essen
da war es bringt mich um weil wir müssen
drehen ja also wir machen heute
schnitten warum schnitten weil ich
möchte euch meine schnitten form
vorstellen und zwar ist die 25 x 10 cm
groß und da könnt ihr immer rezepte
packen wenn er sagt wir sind nun zu
zweit zu dritt oder zu viert und ich
möchte jetzt kuchen nicht drei tage
lagern weil ich dir nicht aufgegessen
kriege und dadurch das haben sie und ich
jetzt hier im haushalt auch zu zweit ist
diese schnitten vom perfekt wenn man
dann nämlich so eine große menge hat
unsere erfrischende maracuja torte
besteht aus folgenden zutaten sie
übrigens nobert wir haben hier einmal
ein plätzchen maracujasaft für die creme
habe ich hier schlagsahne doppel rahmen
frischkäse creme fraiche außerdem
vanille extrakt in eine bio zitrone
zucker und sahne fest und später für den
guss benötigen wir maracujasaft und
magazine und jetzt geht es direkt zu der
zubereitung wir beginnen jetzt
zuallererst mit der sahne die ist ganz
frisch aus dem kühlschrank richtig schön
einigkeit und die gebe ich jetzt in
meine schüsse und ich mache das so dass
ich hier schon von vornherein ein
bisschen mehr seine nehmer 100 gramm
mehr und dann nehme ich mir das gleich
zur seite und dann kann ich das für die
deko benutzen muss nicht extra noch mal
aufschlagen
[Musik]
der saane habe ich auch noch seine fest
hinzu gegeben und dann auf vollster
stufe schön steif geschlagen ich habe
mir jetzt hier auch schon für die deko
etwas beiseite gelegt einfach in einen
spritzbeutel mit offen natürlich rein
gegeben mit auf einer 100 hülle und das
gebe ich jetzt zur seite kommt auch
gleich in den kühlschrank
aber jetzt machen wir erstmal weiter mit
der restlichen creme dafür nehmt ihr
euch eine neue schüsse und gibt da ganz
einfach frischkäse und cremes
rechtsstreit und wenn ihr zum beispiel
keine creme frisch hab dann nimmt
einfach spannend
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die restlichen zutaten sind jetzt auch
schon in der schüssel und grünen wäre es
nur ganz kurz um wirklich nur so für 10
sekunden und dann erheben wir mit dem
tag über die sonne unter
somit ist die creme fertig und die gebe
ich jetzt nur ganz kurz an die seite wir
machen uns auch sofort weiter wichtig
ist dass ihr eure schnitten form jetzt
schon auf eine passende unterlage gibt
denn später den kuchen noch mal um zu
transportieren ist ein bisschen
schwierig wir nehmen jetzt hier einmal
unsere eier plätzchen ihr könntet ihr
zum beispiel auch löffelbiskuits nehme
ist es eigentlich noch geschmackssache
ich finde die aber total lecker und die
tunke ich jetzt für eine sekunde eben
den maracujasaft und dann gebe ich das
auf dem boden und danach kommt die creme
drauf und dann macht ihr so weiter ist
alles aufgebraucht ist
[Musik]
wenn ihr dann die letzte schicht schön
glatt gestrichen haben teurer winkel
palette kommt es für zwei stunden in den
kühlschrank bevor wir den guss drauf
machen können denn im kühlschrank wird
die creme noch richtig schön fest und
dann können auch die schnitten formen
ganz einfach entfernen ohne dass uns da
irgendwas rauswirft
also sage ich mal bis gleich so meine
lieben es geht weiter am herd ich mache
jetzt hier schon mal den guss fertig das
mache ich jetzt 25 minuten bevor die
kühl seite des kopfes zu ende ist und da
gebe ich jetzt einfach den maracujasaft
rein und engagiere und werdet keine agad
ihnen da hat der kann auch ganz einfach
speisestärke benutzen er nimmt sie dann
ganz einfach ein ass bei der agad ihn
ist es so ich verhöre das jetzt jetzt
schalte ich den herd erst ein weiß ich
jetzt verrührt habe und dann las ich
dass zwei stunden lang spielen kochen
und dann hat es auch schon jury
eigenschaften danach lassen wir das 15
minuten abkühlen aber dass ich so ganz
heiß auf die sahne geben sollte
und dann ist der bus auch schon fertig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt habe ich die maracuja glasur
einmal drauf gegeben mit dem löffel
rücken damit das nicht zu viel druck
ausübt und wir die sahne nicht
beschädigen aber wenn ihr alles kühlt
und auch hier mit dem guss 15 minuten
bis 20 minuten wartet dann passiert da
überhaupt nicht ich lasse das jetzt noch
kurz fest wer im kühlschrank das dauert
auch nur so fünf minuten dann dekoriere
ich das ganze mit der restlichen seine
dich mehr aufgehoben habe und dann passt
dazu jetzt am allerbesten maracuja also
frische maracuja und minz aber wie ihr
das dekoriert ist natürlich vollkommen
euch überlassen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und die maracuja split schnitten sind
fertig und sie schmecken einfach so
erfrischend und ich liebe ja wie gesagt
dass maracuja es wird als und deswegen
ist es für mich die perfekte sommerliche
torte die man natürlich auch im winter
zubereiten kann
und das beste ist es ist novak und ich
schreibe euch alle genauen mengenangaben
hier unten in die infobox wir müssen auf
jeden fall ein dummchen nach oben da
lassen wir die bisher hingeschaut habe
und wenn ihr das rezept genauso feuer
wie wir
wir freuen uns gleich ist einfach nur zu
genießen und dann haben wir noch einen
ganz ganz schönen abend und ihr
hoffentlich auch und dann freue ich mich
wenn ihr auch beim nächsten mal wieder
dabei sein auf die skating skis ihr
leben
[Musik]
[Applaus]